The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Thank you all
for uploading all your stuff
last night.
We do watch everything,
just so you know.
And it's a really,
really helpful for us.
So I really appreciate
you guys doing that.
I thought we'd start off today
by doing just a quick exercise
where you say the point of your
video in one to two sentences.
And I think about
this last night.
Because it's actually
a really nuanced thing,
understanding the
difference between what
the point of your video is
and what your videos does.
I was trying to think of a good
way to explain it last night
and this morning.
And I think that
might be the best
way for me to understand it.
And that's why I gave that
example of the snot video,
right?
Because the point of the
video that I made about snot
wasn't to explain what snot is.
That's what my video does.
But the point of it is to show
that this material that you
take for granted,
that's in your body,
actually does all these
xyz amazing things.
So does the difference
between those two things
make sense to you guys?
Or do you recognize
the difference
between those two things?
So for instance, Joshua.
Your video maybe about what
a binary search is, right?
But that's not the
point of your video.
That's what your video does.
In achieving the
point of your video,
explaining why binary
search is, is sort
of a happy afterthought, right?
But it's not what drives
the video forward.
So if we could just
go around and pitch
the point of your video
in one to two sentences.
And the more specific
it is the better, right?
Because we can generalize things
like, the point of my video
is to explain how
amazing snot is.
But that's actually
not that different
from the point of my videos to
explain what snot is, right?
I've just thrown in an
adjective, basically.
So does that sound
OK to everyone?
And I think this will be
helpful because once you really
think of what the
thesis of your video
is it's going to help
you a lot in scripting.
Because you'll always be able
to go back to that big point,
right?
If you're scripting with the
objective of explaining what
a fractal is, that's what
Ulea's video is about it,
it's really easy to get
lost in the details.
So that's the whole
point of this exercise.
Does anyone want to go first?
Otherwise we'll
just go in order.
AUDIENCE: I'll go first.
PROFESSOR: Awesome, thanks Josh.
AUDIENCE: So you were just
highlighting that my video,
it was about the binary
search algorithm.
But I guess the theme here
is why can't find my stuff?
And how can I find it there?
That's what the theme is about.
And the question is
can Google teach me
how to do my own search
in my life better.
PROFESSOR: I think it's a
really good start, right?
Because we were
talking about yesterday
the power of questions.
But again, the point of your
video isn't the question.
The point of your video is
the answer to the question.
So what if you go
from there and try
to go for two sentences that
try to answer those questions.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have an example?
PROFESSOR: Well, wait.
Say the questions again?
AUDIENCE: Why can't
I find my stuff?
And how can I find it better?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So Josh, how can you
find your stuff better?
AUDIENCE: If we keep a list
of, like, where is it located?
Or better yet, if they're
positioned in a way
that has a relationship
among them.
So it's kind of like, if you put
stuff in the toilet, everything
you need to use in the toilet,
you put them in that location.
So you avoid putting
things in places where
they don't need to be there.
But you place the things where
the relationship is natural.
PROFESSOR: So basically
what you're saying
is that the way you
organize objects
isn't just for
aesthetic purposes.
It can actually change
the time and efficiency
in which you find things.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Which doesn't
sound like a big deal
until you realize that
that's the fundamental way
that something as
huge as Google uses.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Does that
feel like more of a point
than this is how a
search engine works?
AUDIENCE: It's more of a point.
PROFESSOR: That's
more of a point?
AUDIENCE: That
sounds like something
more than you're writing down.
I mean, for me, at least, maybe.
I'm a visual person.
But, like, that's a
really important concept
that we just figured out.
Right?
PROFESSOR: It's like, it's
a super nuanced thing.
And very difficult
to figure out.
It's a lot easier to figure
out someone else's point
than your own, actually.
Which is why I wanted you
guys to come up with a script
sometime tomorrow.
It's a lot easier for me,
at least, as an editor
to give productive
feedback when I actually
have something tangible
in front of me.
So your questions were a
really great starting point.
And the script that
you wrote is also
a really great starting point.
Because there's a lot of
material to work with.
But I wouldn't have
been able to figure out
that that was your point unless
I had had those materials,
right?
The questions are a super
good starting point.
Oftentimes the
point of your video
is going to be the answer
to those questions.
So the questions
set up the video.
But the point of the video
is not the questions.
AUDIENCE: It's like the
difference between a symptom
and a disease from a
doctor's perspective, right?
Like, that's a different
way of thinking about it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You keep asking,
like, why is something itching?
Why is something itching?
And then you finally understand
the core reason to why?
I think that's what you're
trying to get across?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And I think it's a
very compelling way
to set up not just video,
but scientific papers, talks.
Any time you're
trying to sell an idea
to someone, grant proposals.
Oftentimes you'll ask somebody
you're going to the conference,
what are you going to do?
And their answer
is well, I'm going
to talk about the
research that I did.
And that's not really helpful.
Obviously, you're going to talk
about the research you did.
What I want to know is
what is your research?
I know that you're going to talk
about binary search, probably
from the title of your video.
What I want to know
is, what is it, right?
So let's do this one more time.
Can you describe the
point of your video
in two sentences or less?
AUDIENCE: The way
we could find things
better is the way we put--
[INAUDIBLE] right now.
PROFESSOR: That's a good start.
That's good.
So the way we can
find things better,
you're trying to
relate a concept
or an everyday
experience that we have,
like organizing things.
So the way we organize things.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The way we find things
better is the way
Google could find
our results better.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
That's a much stronger
point than the questions
you had initially.
Than saying the point is to
explain what binary search is.
And you can flesh that
out a little bit more.
But do you see where
we're going with this?
Ulea, we're going
around doing one
to two sentence explanations
of what our videos are.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Let's
have other people
go since you just got here.
Paul, do you mind going next?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So mine's about using
principles that kids are already
familiar with, like
floating and sinking
to show an application
of navel architecture.
Specifically, how
to prevent ships
from sinking using subdivision
and Archimedes's Law.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So that is very informative.
That's, like, a
perfect description
of what your
video's going to be.
That maybe verbatim what
you put as the summary
in the YouTube video.
Like, that's going to be super
helpful to a teacher who's
looking through the videos
and wanting to find out
what videos are about.
So I guess my question
would be, what
are the actual
principles that kids
learn that would
help them understand
the ship and the subdivision?
AUDIENCE: So kids are familiar
with floating and sinking
because they go through second
grade or something like that.
PROFESSOR: And not just
kids, but everyone.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right.
Right.
PROFESSOR: So you
could start off
"Most people are familiar
with the concepts of flooding
and sinking."
AUDIENCE: Right,
but how you can be
able to divide your
ship so that it can
float when it's [INAUDIBLE].
I think I'm kind of
going in circles.
PROFESSOR: No, no, no.
That's a great start.
And oftentimes what I
personally like a lot--
and maybe this is
something that we've
been repeating over
and over again--
but the whole concept
of the unexpected.
The familiar becoming
unfamiliar, as Chris
was talking about.
The fact that a huge piece
of technical equipment,
like a ship, can be
protected from sinking
using just the basic principles
that even second graders know
is actually really amazing.
All right, so maybe
that's something
that you can sort of play off
of in the point of your video.
That the concepts that we learn
as children, like why things
float and why things sink, are
actually the building blocks
of knowing how to protect
machinery like submarines
from sinking even
when they get damaged.
And the wording of that
obviously isn't super great.
AUDIENCE: But yeah.
That an aircraft
carrier, which is
one of the most complicated
machines ever built--
the fact that it
can even float is
based on this very
simple principle
that you learn in, you know,
first grade or second grade.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think
that's a very strong point
to the video, actually.
I personally love the idea of
complexity from simplicity.
That the things
that people often
think of as being
really complicated,
like naval architecture
or systems biology,
are actually built off
of really simple concepts
and really simple ideas.
Does that makes sense to people?
OK.
David, how about we
go with you next?
AUDIENCE: The point
of my video is
that some people are naturally
predisposed to better survive
the next Ice Age.
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
I didn't hear--
some people are better
disposed to what--
AUDIENCE: Some people are better
predisposed to better survive
the next Ice Age.
PROFESSOR: The next Ice Age?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and they
could be predisposed
by genetically or physically, or
maybe they just do meditation.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yeah, actually that is a point.
That's a thesis,
that's an argument.
And I think that's a
very interesting one.
But notice that the
pitch wasn't why
are some people more
predisposed to this?
Or why do I feel cold
but my friend doesn't?
Right?
The point is an answer
to those questions.
Does anyone have
feedback or suggestions
on maybe ways that David
could alter the point at all?
And again, no one is ever going
to read your point, right?
No one is ever going to
see your thesis written out
before they watch your video.
The idea is that they're
going to watch the video,
and they're going to come
to the same conclusion
that you've written.
So it's OK if the
wording's not perfect.
Because no one's ever
going to read it.
They're just going
to watch your video.
But I guess if you were
going to publish it,
I would open up with have
things like genetic makeup
or physiological
differences among people are
what might predispose certain
humans to survive the next Ice
Age.
Kenneth, do you want to go next?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
The more succinct
point I can think about
is letting them know that time
travel right now is not doable
yet.
Yeah, that's the most
succinct point I can think of.
If you want me to elaborate
a bit more on that,
it's to let you know
that we can possibly
travel forward in time faster.
But traveling back in time
requires too much energy.
PROFESSOR: Too much energy.
OK.
, Again nice distilled point.
I would say that you could
flesh that out a little bit more
for the point.
Because that's, like, time
travel is not possible
is the ultimate argument
that you're making.
But it's a super broad one.
So you can include maybe
why it's not possible.
Again, because it
takes too much energy.
I don't exactly know
what that means.
But maybe your video
is going to cover that?
OK.
Andrea, do you feel
comfortable going?
AUDIENCE: I'll throw
something out there.
Even though I think
it's more what it does.
PROFESSOR: That's OK.
But see, when you throw
that out there, it
makes it a lot easier
for us to give feedback.
It gives us something
to work off of.
AUDIENCE: So the
video illustrates
how engineers in medicine use
natural processes in our bodies
to actually repair or
improve the human body.
PROFESSOR: So I
actually think the point
is in there if you just take
out the first three words.
Engineers and-- what
was it-- scientists
use natural processes
in our bodies to what?
AUDIENCE: Enhance it.
To improve or repair.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
I actually think
the point is in there
if you just get rid
of the "my video explains."
AUDIENCE: Which is
kind of awesome,
considering where she
started two days ago, right?
Like, the braces, you
totally done the [INAUDIBLE].
It's awesome.
AUDIENCE: That's what
you asked me to do.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it was awesome.
I'm saying it was awesome!
Way to go.
PROFESSOR: Nathan,
you want to go?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We aren't the only
ones who eat our food.
And life without them
would be a lot different.
PROFESSOR: That's pretty good!
That's pretty good!
Nathan had an aha
moment last night,
if you heard his reflection.
And I'm really excited to
see where you go with that.
But very, very different
point and answer
to my question than the one
you gave, like, yesterday even.
So I asked him what the point
of his video was yesterday.
And he was like, to explain
what decomposition is.
But do you see
how this is, like,
a completely different point?
And a much more engaging one?
And in explaining and
getting to that point,
he is going to cover
what decomposition is.
All right, Ulea.
AUDIENCE: Mine is
repeating patterns
called fractals are present in
every facet of our existence
and are indispensable in
nature, research, medicine,
and technology.
In that way, mathematics helps
us explore and understand
the world around us.
PROFESSOR: Nice.
Nice.
Any feedback on that one?
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Repeating patterns
called fractals
are present in every
facet of our existence
and are indispensable in
nature, research, medicine,
and technology.
In that way, math helps
us explore and understand
the world around us.
PROFESSOR: That's also a super
different point than the one
you had given yesterday, right?
Yesterday the
point of your video
was-- it wasn't even
like, what is a fractal?
It was like, what is the
philosophy of math, right?
AUDIENCE: No, it was was
math even real, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that
was two days, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but you've
come so far in narrowing
this concept, it's awesome.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
hopefully with these points
it's going to help you
script a tighter set of text.